this morning Britain's Prince Andrew is
responding to sexual abuse allegations
against Jeffrey Epstein for the first
time since his longtime friend hanged
himself in jail Queen Elizabeth's middle
son says in a statement through
Buckingham Palace that he is appalled by
Epstein's alleged crimes that follows
newly released video showing Andrew
inside Epstein's New York mansion back
in 2010 Charlie d'Agata is outside
buckin palace with more on this Charlie
is this statement unusual do you think
it is highly unusual in the very fact
that the palace decided to release a
statement at all just shows you how
seriously they're now taking this
situation and here's why it was in
response to this video allegedly showing
Prince Andrew waving goodbye to a young
woman at Epstein's Manhattan mansion
purportedly shot in 2010 and taken less
than an hour after Epstein left the
house with another young woman the
prince even appears to check that no one
was looking
but cameras were which is forced
Buckingham Palace to state his royal
highness deplores the exploitation of
any human being and the suggestion he
would condone participate in or
encourage any such behavior is abhorrent
abhorrent but the accusations go back to
at least two thousand one in this
picture showing Prince Andrew with
alleged victim Virginia gue Frey who's
only 15 at the time a British socialite
ghilane Maxwell
she says Maxwell acted as a madam
passing her around to Epstein's friends
it started with one and then it trickled
into two and so on and so forth and you
know before you know it I'm being lent
out to politicians and to academics and
to people that you roll T unsealed court
documents allege goo Frei was trafficked
to Prince Andrew a claim that was
previously dismissed by a judge and
struck from the record royal
correspondent Roy and Nika says the
palace finally had no choice but to
react ever since Jeffrey Epstein
died it's there's been mansion
speculation about what further evidence
could come out about the GP or now the
only issue is with this statement the
palace have to be pretty confident that
no
evidence is going to come forward
further implicating the Duke of York and
his connection with Jeffrey Epstein now
it's important to note this happened in
2010 this is two years after Epstein was
charged and found guilty of sex crimes
critics say Prince Andrew should have
cut off that relationship there and then
Anthony all right Charlie d'Agata in
London thanks Charlie the same time
interesting piece of New York Times over
the weekend on EPS t's last days in
prison 750 prisoners in the Metropolitan
Correctional Center only 18 guards or
staff ten of whom were working overtime
so you see we're overworked there we
look at those numbers yeah very
interesting reporting